en varios vídeos ya hemos hablado de la
elasticidad precio de la oferta en este
vídeo vamos a analizar de manera más
profunda y vamos a pensar en qué
factores pueden hacer que la curva de la
oferta o puntos en la oferta o partes de
ella tengan una forma más elástica o
inelástica así que vamos a pensar en los
determinantes de la elasticidad precio
de la oferta y para ayudarnos a pensar
en esto dibuje dos curvas de ofertas
distintas recuerda la elasticidad precio
es pensar en qué tan sensible es la
cantidad en este caso ofrecida mejor la
elasticidad precio de la oferta es
pensar en qué tan sensible es el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad ofertada ante
un cambio porcentual en el precio así
que por ejemplo si vamos de este precio
a este otro observa que es un cambio
porcentual bastante considerable
precio parece un cambio porcentual en el
precio cercano a un 50 por ciento
ahora si observamos esta curva de la
oferta parece que casi casi estamos
completamente vertical y no está
completamente vertical pero es muy
ascendente podemos ver que nuestro
cambio porcentual en la cantidad va de
aquí a acá no es tan dramático entonces
estas partes de la curva que están
relativamente ascendentes que se
aproximan cada vez más a una vertical
las consideramos como ofertas in
elásticas relativas si tuviéramos una
curva perfectamente vertical o partes de
ella que estuviera perfectamente
vertical en esas partes puedes decir que
tienes una oferta perfectamente
inelástica
por otra parte en este otro ejemplo si
cambiamos de este precio a este otro es
decir si esta vez tenemos un cambio
porcentual pequeño en el precio observa
que podría resultar un cambio porcentual
bastante grande en la cantidad ofrecida
vamos de aquí hasta acá entonces cuando
estamos más horizontales o es más plana
nuestra curva de oferta
hablamos de una elasticidad tenemos una
elasticidad relativa somos mucho más
elásticos aquí de lo que éramos en el
ejemplo anterior por otra parte si somos
perfectamente horizontales tendríamos
una parte de la curva de la oferta
perfectamente elástica o de alguna tabla
de la oferta ahora bien cuáles son los
factores que nos dan mayor en
elasticidad o una mayor elasticidad
bueno imagina que estamos en un mundo
que empieza con este precio donde está
es nuestra cantidad imagina que las
fábricas que producen sea cual sea el
bien están a plena producción y para
producir más tomaría mucho tiempo o
simplemente no tenemos los recursos para
tener más producción tal vez la gente
que está en las fábricas estén haciendo
otras cosas en estos momentos tal vez
tengas otros recursos otros insumos en
tu producción que simplemente no estén
disponibles tal vez no se petróleo
imagina que se está produciendo tanto
petróleo en el mundo como es posible y
ese es un insumo para nuestra producción
en ese escenario incluso si el precio
aumenta de manera dramática aunque los
empresarios quieran producir una mayor
cantidad no podrán simplemente porque no
tienen más fábricas o no tienen más
insumos o recurso
para producir una mayor cantidad por lo
tanto la producción aumentará un poco
podrían dirigir mejor las fábricas a lo
largo de este tiempo o puede ser que las
personas que estén entrenadas para hacer
esa actividad en específico trabajen
horas extras y que tal vez no sé no
existan más personas que hagan esa
actividad entonces no puedes producir
mucho más un par de cosas que podemos
recoger de este ejemplo es que esta y la
elasticidad de la oferta tiende a pasar
a corto plazo a corto plazo porque a
corto plazo no puedes construir una
nueva fábrica no eres capaz de encontrar
más recursos a corto plazo digamos
encontrar petróleo a corto plazo no eres
capaz de entrenar a más personal en un
corto plazo para producir más así que sí
estamos hablando de una curva de oferta
que describe
un periodo de tiempo a corto plazo
entonces esta tenderá a ser más
inelástica y otro factor determinante es
y ya hemos hablado de esto es que no
existan muchos recursos disponibles una
vez más tu fábrica está operando en
plena producción estás contratando a
todos los que puedan producir aquella
cosa que produces o que el mundo esté
produciendo tanto como se pueda de algún
recurso natural que necesitas como
insumo para producir ese bien bueno
vayamos a la otra situación qué factores
determinan la elasticidad en esta
ocasión estamos en un escenario observa
a largo plazo es más fácil producir más
recursos y a largo plazo podemos
construir más fábricas podemos encontrar
contratar y entrenar más empleados
etcétera por lo tanto el largo plazo del
que estamos hablando tiende a conducir a
una
de oferta con mayor elasticidad y otra
noción aquí es que no hay capacidad
limitada o déjame escribirlo así que no
hay recursos limitados
tal vez nuestras fábricas no estén
trabajando una capacidad máxima así que
incluso un aumento pequeño en el precio
donde digamos hey sólo voy a hacer que
nuestras fábricas produzcan un poco más
o tal vez existan muchas personas que
ayuden a producir más o que tengan las
habilidades que sean necesarias para
producir más de este bien por lo que si
el precio aumenta se puede contratar más
personas que empiecen a producir este
bien o tal vez se usen recursos sin
escasez alguna ya que si el precio
aumenta entonces se pueden usar más y
más y más de estos recursos para
proporcionar más y más y más de estos
bienes
en fin espero que todo esto tenga
sentido para ti nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima